If you’ve ever driven a car – legally, that is – you
know before you taste that sweet, sweet vehicular
freedom you had totake a really fun test.
No, not the practical one where you parallel park
between two cones like your life depends on it.
The learner’s permit exam, the test of all
tests.
You probably studied for it with a real snooze-worthy
booklet or some informational government website.
You had to learn all the rules of the road
before getting to touch the road.
Well, in a car at least.
Whenever you’re learning a new skill, there’s a
certain amount of theoretical knowledge you need
before you’re ready to sit in “the driver’s seat.”
It’s the same for media literacy.
These days we’re so inundated with media it’s
impossible to teach someone all the skills they need.
It’s like we skipped the driving exam and
woke up behind the wheel of a moving racecar!
Luckily, it’s never too late to dust off
the ol’ driver’s manual.
So far on Crash Course Media Literacy, we’ve
covered everything from how literacy was born
to how our brains handle messages.
We’ve talked about theories and principles,
but now it’s time to really get behind the wheel.
[Theme Music]
In our first episode we discussed the
National Association of Media Literacy
Educators’ definition:
“The ability to access, analyze, evaluate,
create, and act using all forms of communication.”
These five skills are your toolbox encountering
media in the wild.
If you’re watching this video, you may take
the first skill, access, for granted.
To play this YouTube video you need a device
that can connect to the internet – a smartphone,
computer, or a tablet.
Plus, that device needs software for video
and audio playback.
Then of course you need an internet connection,
one fast enough to stream this video.
To some of us, being constantly connected
to the internet is an everyday thing.
But these things cost money, and in the U.S.,
many people can’t access the internet.
At least 5 million kids don’t have internet
access at home
and for many poor families, places like the
local library or a McDonald’s with free wifi are
the only places they can get online.
Think about how often you use the internet,
and for what.
You have probably used it to complete homework
or apply for a job or file taxes.
All of these things seem essential and easy
to do – if you have the means.
Practice makes perfect, right?
A kid who grows up without regular internet
access will have lower digital skill levels than
their peers who access it easily.
And, as I’m sure you know, digital skills are
crucial to functioning in our high-tech world.
That means many people who don’t have this
access are behind before they even start school.
In July 2016, the United Nations declared
internet access a basic human right.
They said, “Everyone has the right to
freedom of opinion and expression;
this right includes freedom to hold
opinions without interference
and to seek, receive and impart information
and ideas through any media and regardless
of frontiers.”
The internet may seem like it makes everything
way more accessible.
You can just Google what you need rather than
lug around a set of encyclopedias.
But access remains unevenly distributed.
The other side of the coin is our second skill,
analyze.
If and when you do have access, you’re
flooded with way too much information and way
too many sources of entertainment.
Locating the highest quality content –
whether you’re looking for a reliable source of
news or a TV show you like, or a series of charming
and educational YouTube videos –
this requires you to analyze what
you’re looking at.
The foundation of media analysis is
acknowledging that all media is constructed with
a purpose and a particular point of view.
Media literacy scholar Renee Hobbs
recommends answering five questions when
you make a media choice,
Number 1: Who created this message and what
is the purpose?
Is it a movie made by Disney for entertainment?
Is it an ad made by Apple to sell phones and
computers?
Number 2: What techniques does it use to attract
and hold attention?
Does the message include persuasive elements
to convince you its story is true?
Is it flashy and loud like a pop-up ad, or
have a cliffhanger-y headline to suck you in?
Number 3: What lifestyles, values and points
of view does it depict?
Is it representing a single point of view,
like an autobiography?
Is it an Instagram feed that’s all about
that hashtag beach life or a blog that’s all
about working hard and playing hard?
Number 4: How might different people interpret
this message?
Would your parents or grandparents or best
friend feel the same way about this?
How would they react?
Number 5: What is omitted, or left out?
Is this article about politics talking about
every party or just one?
Did that break-up song mention the good times,
too?
Why or why not?
Once you’ve established answers to these
questions, it’s time to evaluate the quality and
credibility of the media you’re consuming.
Media literacy scholar Julie Coiro says
there are four key things to look out for:
relevance, accuracy, bias, and reliability.
The first is relevance.
Does the info or media serve its purpose,
and to what degree?
If you Googled “recipes for chow mein”
and recipe for peach muffins comes up instead,
that content is not relevant.
This one can be a pretty low bar to clear.
As we know, our mind loves to accept the
easiest to understand info as the right info,
because it’s convenient.
Which is why we move on to…accuracy.
Evaluating something for accuracy can be difficult
when you’re just learning about it yourself.
The first step is to check how factual it is.
Are its claims backed up by empirical evidence
or is it just someone’s opinion?
You should be able to double check those facts
with other sources.
Of course, just because multiple outlets tell
the same story doesn’t mean it’s true.
Like how every time there’s a hurricane,
someone photoshops a shark into the waters
and local news stations run the story.
In cases like these, take that info and double
check with their source.
Next, you look for bias, or someone’s perspective.
Be sure to distinguish whether the author of the media you’re evaluating is slanting the facts towards a particular point of view, and ask how that reflects on the publisher.
Biased media can obscure reality by presenting
only the evidence that supports one opinion.
To ward this off, it’s always great to seek out
diverse perspectives on a topic and look for
evidence to support any stance that you take.
Finally, determining reliability can help
you find sources of information that you trust.
Reliability is how trustworthy a publisher
or author is based on the entirety of their work.
Yes, it’s complicated.
As you know, some respected publishers
who are reliable sources publish native ads
that look like news.
Some even promote those sketchy click-bait
tabloid ads about celebrities dying or losing weight.
By consistently evaluating for relevance,
accuracy, and bias, you can determine whether
a publisher’s work is reliable on the whole.
Let’s take this four-part evaluation for
a spin in the Thought Bubble!
Consider this article from The Washington
Post, from November 2017.
The headline reads: FCC net neutrality process
‘corrupted’ by fake comments and vanishing
consumer complaints, officials say.
It’s about a new rule the Federal Communications
Commission was set to vote on the next month.
The FCC put out a call for citizens to
comment on the decision to roll back
net neutrality protections.
Some said the comment process wasn’t fair
and that bad actors manipulated it to get their way.
So, is this relevant?
Well if you came across this article because you
were searching for Titanic fanfic, you’d say no.
But if you came across it on social media and
were interested in this net neutrality battle, you’d
certainly find its information relevant. Check.
Is it accurate?
The Washington Post’s reporter explains
the net neutrality comments process and
the allegations against it.
They cite credible sources along the way,
like the New York Attorney General, an FCC
spokesperson, and a data scientist.
They also link to other stories that back
up their claims throughout.
It looks pretty accurate.
Check.
Is it biased?
This article doesn’t just quote the FCC
in this story about the FCC.
They also gave space to the New York Attorney
General and the leader of an advocacy group that
are against the FCC’s net neutrality decision.
They present both sides of this fight, and
include a third party, the data scientist, to
offer a neutral opinion.
That’s a good way to fight off bias.
Check.
Is it reliable?
The Washington Post is well-known for a
history of quality journalism and has won dozens
of Pulitzer Prizes (the Oscars for journalism).
The article was written by Brian Fung, their
technology writer who has written about internet
access quite a bit before.
He’s also written for the National Journal
and The Atlantic, two other reliable publications.
This checks out for reliability.
See, it only takes a minute to go through
this four-step check with a bit of news.
You can use this whenever you come across
media you find questionable.
It’s an important skill to have.
Thanks Thought Bubble!
Maybe the most fun media literacy skill is
to create media yourself.
Taking your knowledge of how media are produced and
producing some of your own is actually a great way to
develop skills in analyzing and evaluating media, too.
It’s like media literacy inception.
But you don’t have to be some music producer
or artist to create media.
Posting to social networks is creating media.
Writing a blog is creating media.
Making a funny GIF from your favorite TV show
is creating media.
Finally, the most important part of media
literacy is being able to act on all of the
skills you’ve acquired.
Acting on media literacy could mean looking
up local candidates for government and using
that info when you vote.
It could mean going vegan after reading about
animal farms.
It could even mean deleting Twitter from your
phone after realizing you’re addicted to social media.
You may be wondering: do everyday people
really access, analyze, evaluate, create and act on
all the media they consume each day?
Of course not.
It’s impossible to apply each of these principles
to everything we absorb all the time.
But little by little as you start to apply
them to different media it will become a habit.
Like building a muscle, you’ll find yourself
doing it reflexively as you scroll through
your phone or listen to the radio.
And as a key tenet of media literacy, you
should be able to accomplish this across all
of your devices and types of media.
Not just the news and advertisements, but
movies and music and books, too.
You might use multiple devices in the span
of one day and,
in that one day see videos, photos, news articles,
ads, short stories, quizzes, sponsored content –
you name it.
As long as you know how to access what you
want, what to trust, and who you can rely on for it, you’ll
thrive within the fast-paced media environment.
But we’re not done yet.
Next time on Crash Course Media Literacy we’re
going to talk about how media literacy itself is
going to change in the future.
How will we respond to virtual and augmented
reality media?
How does artificial intelligence factor into
our news diet?
Should we even let corporations sell us “smart
home” devices that listen to us all the time?
There’s a lot to cover, and I can’t wait
to dive in.
For Crash Course, I’m Jay Smooth.
See you next time!
Crash Course Media Literacy is filmed in the
Dr. Cheryl C. Kinney Studio in Missoula, MT.
It’s made with the help of all of these
nice people, and our animation team is
Thought Cafe.
Crash Course is a Complexly production.
If you wanna keep imagining the world complexly
with us check out some of our other channels,
like Sexplanations, How To Adult, and Healthcare
Triage.
If you'd like to keep Crash Course free for everyone,
forever, you can support the series at Patreon,
a crowdfunding platform that allows
you to support the content you love.
Thank you to all of our patrons for making
Crash Course possible with their continued
support.